what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and it looks like Marvel Studios has a
lot of plans to try and spice up the MCU
as it currently stands make it more
exciting and in a very weird and ironic
way Marvel Studios is actually in a good
position right now to kind of
restructure the plans they had for the
future of the MCU especially with Phase
5 and Phase 6 to redo some things and
make it even better and that is exactly
what they are doing right now it's
unfortunate that Jonathan major was
found guilty and they are recasting him
as king the Conqueror and in doing so
that has pushed back their plans for
Avengers King Dynasty which is
reportedly now called Avengers 5 and
other movies have been delayed as well
but again this is for a good cause so
Marvel Studios can do the best they can
with these projects that they have
coming out and it sounds like Marvel
Studios kind of has plans for sort of
mini Avengers films Avengers films on a
smaller scale before the other big
Avengers films come come out and
honestly based off of what we've heard
so far about Avengers 5 it sounds like
these many Avengers style films are
going to be better and more exciting
than Avengers 5 insiders have recently
told us a little bit about the roster
for Avengers 5 and it sounds fine if
they write a really good story it could
be a really good movie however I've seen
a lot of people comment and say well
this current lineup is kind of
lackluster however the movie right now
is undergoing some pretty big changes
some pretty big rewrites because King
the Conqueror is no longer going to be
the focus of the movie so I have faith
that they'll turn it around and make a
killer movie and in the meantime we can
enjoy these other movies that they are
releasing that are basically going to be
kind of like Captain America Civil War
that movie was basically an Avengers
film without the official title that is
their plan for a few other films coming
up in the MCU soon which is super
exciting so let's dive into what these
films are going to be and if you're new
be sure to subscribe so you don't miss
out on any of the latest MC news and if
you subscribe and leave a comment you're
automatically entered in our giveaway
for chance to win a PS5 an Xbox series X
some Marvel Legends items or DC items
the winner picks one item and we pick
one winner at the end of every month so
what's really interesting is that the
next film that we are going to get from
Marvel Studios is Deadpool 3 because
this was not supposed to be the order
that Deadpool 3 came out in but as many
of you know many of the MCU projects
were delayed from 2024 to 2025 and now
Deadpool 3 is the only movie coming from
Marvel Studios in 2024 and if you've
been keeping up with news for Deadpool 3
you know that this movie is going to be
just absolutely huge in fact this movie
has the potential to be bigger than an
actual Avengers film because this film
is going to involve well Deadpool first
and foremost which is just super
exciting as it is to have him in the MCU
but then you add Hugh Jackman returning
as Wolverine with Deadpool and then some
of the original X-Men that alone right
there the original X-Men from the fox
Universe from X-Men number one X2 and X3
three The Last Stand some of those
iconic characters in the MCU that is
just more than a lot of fans could ever
really ask for but then on top of that
you add the fact that there are going to
be variants of a lot of other characters
that we know and love in this movie as
well it gets even more exciting because
we could potentially see Iron Man
variants Black Widow variants Spider-Man
variants and it's been said that we're
actually going to get Wolverine variants
in the film as well as Deadpool goes to
different universes he is searching for
the true Wolverine and in doing so he
sees a bunch of different Wolverine
variants until he decides that Hugh
Jackman's is the best which right now
all fans would probably agree with the
exception of the height so this one is a
no-brainer it's obviously going to be an
insanely huge film it will most likely
involve some Avengers and will
definitely involve some X-Men plus not
to mention this film is supposed to
directly set up the events of Avengers
Secret Wars and really the kind of
destruction of the Multiverse so it's
going to be extremely important now the
next one is Captain America 4 Brave new
world and this one is kind of supposed
to be a new Avengers film obviously it's
gone through some changes as well and
ultimately the story is going to be
about Sam Wilson's Captain America
fighting Fus Thunderbolt Ross as the Red
Hulk now they've done some re-shoot
recently but before the Insiders were
reporting that essentially the new
Avengers team would start to be
established in this film and here's
something really cool it sounds like
throughout multiple films there's kind
of going to be a civil war that starts
conflict between superheroes is going to
start to arise it's said that end dared
of a born again Kingpin will become
mayor of New York City in which he will
then pass a law that makes being a
vigilante a crime and we already know
that it's going to bleed into other
films like Spider-Man 4 but I think
we're going to kind of see a lot of this
start to happen in Captain America Brave
New World as well because this is where
we're going to start to see that the
president of the United States
Thunderbolt Ross is corrupt and he is
still experimenting with super soldier
serum no doubt Sam Wilson wants to go up
against him and wants to take him down
and expose him however there might be
some other Heroes who don't want to go
up against the president of the United
States which of course would make sense
but Captain America being who he is Sam
Wilson having his sense of righteousness
of course will want to go up against him
and he might decide that he needs some
help and this is where the reports of
the new Avengers team kind of being
assembled in this film come into play
Alex perz from the cosmic circus stated
that if the Avengers teamed up tomorrow
this would be the current lineup he
guesses Captain America Captain Marvel
Falcon Hulk Wong Valkyrie shanqi ktie
Ant-Man and the WASP I don't think we'll
see all these characters in Captain
America 4 in fact I know we won't but I
do think we'll see Falcon in fact that's
confirmed the new Falcon will be in this
movie I do believe we are going to see
Hulk in fact some insiders have reported
this it would make sense for Wong to
show up since he is the sorcerer Supreme
currently in the MCU and since Sam
Wilson has fought with Ant-Man before in
Captain America Civil War it would make
sense that he would call him back up
again however since he's in California
this might just be a quick Cameo with a
phone call or FaceTime to Scott Lang in
which him and possibly wasp could show
up as well so a lot of potential for
Captain America Brave New World and they
even have decided to reshoot some scenes
to make them better which is just
awesome because that means they're
taking the time and the care into this
movie to make it good then something
that we talked about yesterday is
Spider-Man 4 if you really want to dive
into all of the details you can check
out the video I did about this yesterday
but basically the events of Daredevil
and Captain America 4 are going to bleed
into Spider-Man 4 Kingpin makes being a
vigilante illegal Matt Murdoch AKA
Daredevil is going to be doing a lot of
lawyer work defending Vigilantes and we
believe that's how him and Spider-Man
come in contact with each other now of
course Matt Murdoch did meet Peter
Parker in Spider-Man no way home but now
we know that nobody knows who Peter
Parker is anymore however Matt Murdock
did know that Peter was Spider-Man so he
should still know who Spider-Man is
although keep in mind Spider-Man does
not know that Matt Murdoch is Daredevil
not yet at least but Spider-Man 4 has
been said to be somewhat of a civil war
film as well having multiple heroes in
this film and insiders have actually
stated that Miles Morales will be
introduced in the new Spider-Man film so
he could be introduced in Spider-Man 4
although if he is introduced right away
in Spider-Man 4 I think he'll probably
just be introduced as miles and not
another Spider-Man I think they'll
probably save that for Spider-Man 5 or
Spider-Man 6 so three awesome films that
are kind of going to be these Mini Avers
films and then of course we'll get
Avengers 5 which is currently being
Rewritten and yesterday we actually
learned from Justin craw who is a senior
film reporter over at deadline stating
that there is going to be a lot of
Marvel news coming very soon but he does
State don't expect the recasting news
for Kang anytime soon here's what he
stated in a tweet yesterday see a lot
who will play Kang next and here is a
top Contender for Kang comments this
week and all I'll say is this don't
expect that news anytime soon there will
be plenty of Marvel breaks in coming
weeks on various fronts but don't hold
your breath on that one he then replied
to his tweet stating this isn't
dismissing any rumor this week about
potential contenders for this role I
don't have any intel on those being true
or not true it's just letting you know
if I were betting what gets announced
first king or the field I'd put money on
the field and side note many people have
speculated that he could be talking
about the Fantastic forecast the
official fantastic forecast finally
released by Marvel Studios in which
filming for the Fantastic 4 is supposed
to start in a few months which means the
cast will probably leak out if Marvel
Studios doesn't announce it by then so
it would make sense that Marvel would
announce it pretty soon so basically
don't expect any official news about the
Kang recasting within a few months we
also could possibly get a new title for
Avengers 5 many people have speculated
and some insiders have stated that
Marvel Studios contingency plans were
for Dr Doom to come into the MCU if
Majors was found guilty however there
have been some pretty conflicting
reports about this some insiders state
that Doom is an option for them and some
people state that it really wasn't ever
an option for them and a lot of people
think that Doom deserves his own Saga
which of course I do as well he is one
of the biggest and best villains to ever
come from Marvel he shouldn't be the
villain of one movie get defeated and
then no longer be a part of the MCU and
Marvel Studios would be stupid to do
that however he could be introduced as a
villain for now sort of on a smaller
scale and start to get built up to be
the incredible Doom that he is in the
next Saga in fact I would personally
love if they introduced Victor Von Doom
right now started to build him as a
villain and then in the next Saga both
the X-Men and the Fantastic 4 and then
the Avengers as well all have to go up
against him as the big bat I think that
would be an incredible movie but as of
right now there is a possibility that he
could be a villain or the villain of
Avengers 5 but unfortunately we'll have
to wait a little bit until we find out
what exactly Avengers 5 is going to be
about but let me know what you think
about these other little mini Avengers
scale films in the comments down below
does this news get you excited about
these films or are you currently kind of
concerned about the state of the MCU let
us know your thoughts Down Below in the
comments don't forget to like this video
And subscribe so you can stay up to date
on the MCU you can find us on Instagram
and Twitter as well and as always thank
you all so much for watching woof
woof